he's Chris Sims the popular Chris Sims
joining us on loan from Pro Football
Talk yeah here to assess the draft what
did you make of the Browns strategy
there last night Chris well listen I'm
not gonna sit I never say I'm totally
mad at a football team that took players
in a position of need and very important
positions at that who they had graded at
a very high level obviously so I mean
I'm not going to sit here and go oh wow
that was the dumbest thing I've ever
seen but I mean then could I drop the
Victor Mayfield number one no I would
not have had the cojones to make that
pick I'm not attracted Baker Mayfield in
the top five for a number of reasons
that we can get into that but my biggest
problem is with the whole thing is I
truly believe they should if they were
gonna go Baker Mayfield they should have
gone say Quon Berkeley one and Baker
Mayfield at number four that would have
made more sense I know they don't know
what the Jets were going to do they got
the guy they wanted I guess certainly
but yeah I mean this talk was out there
that the Jets favored Arnold if he was
there on the board so to me that's where
I look at it a little wrong yeah I'm
right there with you that I know what I
have in SE Kwan Barclay at least I have
a really good idea what I have in shake
one Barclay and worst case scenario we
don't you know end up with Baker
Mayfield and we take Bradley Chubb I
have two guys who come in right away and
help me right away and I know that
you're you know John Dorsey the GM is
going you know this is this is something
that's gonna take a little time here
we're not gonna do it overnight I just
want to know did I get somebody that you
can absolutely positively say is going
to be a star potential star in five
years and I don't know if the Cleveland
Browns accomplished that I don't know if
they did either that is that is the
million-dollar question I think that's
the way to put it - you're right I mean
Bradley job we know what he's going to
be I mean I mean I would be shocked if
Bradley chelev is in a high-level pass
rusher that gets anywhere from 8 to 10
sacks of the year and now they'll listen
I know they had more of a need at the
corner position but man still even as
that you know
Denzel work number four really good
players don't get me wrong here but
man I mean if he was better than Jair
Alexander or Mike Hughes to me it was by
a hair
I really thought those players were
every bit as good as he was so that's
where I push it push back against it as
well but I'm not gonna sit here and just
totally crap all over the Browns because
they got the guys they wanted I'm not
gonna be too mad about that but yes it's
a little iffy in my eyes
does it bother you Baker Mayfield didn't
show up last night
no it does not in fact I actually I kind
of liked it I kind of find it refreshing
you know I mean I think he's a a true
football guy that wanted to enjoy a very
special moment with his family and not
have to worry about cameras and
strangers being in the house I probably
would have taken the the same type of
approach like nobody in the nobody in
the house why I'm being picked and then
maybe after I get picked I go do one
interview or something like that but III
have no problem with what he did what
about you did you not not like them via
there no I didn't bother me you know
these guys have been picked over the
criticized character issues you know let
me let me you know keep asking those
same questions there and he probably
just said let me just control it once I
haven't been able to control it now I'm
controlling it and I'm gonna do it in my
house with my family and he did one
interview and he did it with Jimmy
Kimmel on fine with that okay who
started who starts a game first out of
the quarterback selected last night it
won't be Josh Talent
at this point I mean I just looked at
okay we'll take one more Jackson out of
that obviously right Josh Rosen I mean
he's certainly the most ready
what does they want to throw him out
there the thing I find fascinating with
the Arizona Cardinals is really they
have three quarterbacks that are very
similar a little less athletic than
you'd like at this day and age a little
bit of a thinner frame and all three
other guys can throw it but yeah I think
I'm gonna go with Josh Elam because I
think he's gonna fit that system up in
Buffalo I think there's a true love
affair that we all heard about them
liking Josh Allen through the knock
draft process and when he gets on the
field next to AJ McCarron it's gonna be
hard to stop the buzz once the players
see just how much more physically
superior he is
he's just such a big strong athlete and
and Dan as you and I have talked I mean
it's one of the strongest arms we've
ever seen to come into the NFL ever in
the history of the league yeah I wonder
what about Sam Donald with the Jets I
know you got Josh McCown but at 20 years
of age
can you can you put him in there in that
Jets environment yeah you can he
certainly can handle you know the New
York media the pressure of the situation
I love Sam Donald the person he's the
man I mean he's the kind of guy I would
love to be the face of my organization
but he's young they're one of the big
reasons I push back on Sam Donald being
a slam dunk number one pick was people
in the media were arguing he was the
safest pick and I wanted to say no he
might have a very high ceiling and you
can argue here as the highest ceiling
that's fine but to say the guy that
doesn't have the strongest arms not the
best athlete is the most wrong in the
pocket is the most raw decision-maker
and led college football and turnovers
is the safest pick no that was what was
crazy to me with the Sam Darnell talk
throughout this draft but I do think he
has an incredibly bright future but you
did compliments and Arnold I think in a
way that say he's got the perfect
temperament for New York because he's
boring like your dad yes exactly like my
dad and Eli you ever watched my dad an
old interview I mean you'll fall asleep
it's horrible but that's kind of what it
takes to be successful yeah in New York
because if you do like the nightlife and
the Lima and all that as we all know it
could get become a very slippery slope
here in New York City who is your Rookie
of the Year oh man it's hard for me not
to go with that guy at number two and
and Berkeley just because he's the best
running back I've seen come out in the
draft since I've been evaluating I mean
just even TV scouting he looked amazing
and I just go this modern-day NFL how
coaches can use running backs in the
pass game and just the special kind of
player he is that's the fact that you're
not gonna be able to hone in on him and
go oh we're gonna use all our defensive
resources to stop him and we'll just
leave Odell Beckham jr. one on one
outside yeah good luck without if that's
the case so it would be hard for me not
to thanks take one right now thank you
Chris enjoy the weekend always great to
catch up with you
thanks buddy I'll talk to you man happy
a good have a good weekend as I tried to
say that be good thank you Chris that's
Chris Sims pro football talk on NBCSN
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]